hey guys it's Justine and oh boy the
rumors are already happening like
they've been talking about the iPhone 14
since the iPhone 12. so here we are we
are in the year of the iPhone 15. it
kind of feels so weird to say that like
it's crazy to think the F-15 is going to
be here before we know it so as per
usual we've got some rumors so this
photo recently just leaked and this is
on Mac rumors and this is supposedly an
image of the iPhone 15 design in full
and I love that there is so much
branding over top of this to say who
leaked it that you basically can't even
see the image at all this literally
could be anything we get it we get it
you leaked the image congratulations I
guess what you can sort of tell from
this is it looks like the dynamic Island
and the area for the camera and
everything is still going to be in the
same place so that looks pretty similar
but what this does also show off is here
is showing us the bottom of the iPhone
which that my friends is USBC but that
unfortunately is probably because apple
is being forced because of all the
regulations to switch the phones over to
USBC but for me I'm excited about that
because that is one less cable that I am
gonna have to carry but honestly
lightning is still going to be supported
for many years on because a lot of the
older iPhones people still have people
are still buying the cables for those
phones so I feel like lightning is going
to be around for many many years
speaking of cables you guys should check
out I think ijustinecables.com and get
some pink cables for yourself we've got
USBC Thunderbolt and lightning anyway so
saying that this is the entry level
iPhone 15 there's no major design
changes compared to the iPhone 14. it's
also saying that rumors have indicated
that the dynamic Island will also be
coming to the lower entry models of the
15 so just like the regular 15 and the
15 plus so that's kind of exciting so
now everyone will get to experience that
wonderful trip to the dynamic Island so
now here on Mac Rumors they have an
entire page that's dedicated to iPhone
15 rumors so let's take a look at this
and get more in depth the standard
iPhone 15 models will get upgraded to
the a16 chip while the 15 Pro Models
could get an improved three nanometer
a17 chip now Pro Models could also see
an upgrade to Titanium frames along with
a periscope lens camera technology for
improvements to zoom that's going to be
exciting and that's really the reason
that a lot of us do end up going the Pro
Models is because the camera system does
have slight improvements over the lower
end models pricing on the 15 is expected
to be about the same standard entry
level 6.1 inch devices starting at 7.99
and the 6.7 inch iPhone 15 plus starting
at 8.99 now the design is where I'm
getting hyped up so they're saying that
the rumor suggests that the iPhone 15
models will look similar to the 14 but
the pill and hole cutout will expand the
entire lineup of course the other major
design change is USBC look at that USBC
Port just shining shimmering it is so
Splendid hyped for that now another
rumor is suggesting based on those CAD
drawings that the new 15 could be a
little bit larger it could have a 6.2
inch screen instead of a 6.1 inch
display I just feel like a little bit
bigger of a screen like I'm not mad
about it but also when I picked up the
iPhone Mini the other day I forgot how
incredibly small that thing was and I do
feel like now that I even have the
smaller MacBook I'm like man I kind of
think I want to Pare down my items I
want things to be smaller more portable
but I don't know the max display it just
looks great they're also saying that all
iPhone 15 models could be equipped with
a more power efficient OLED display
which is nice and this right here
stopped me in my tracks took my breath
away the iPhone 15 models
color options
could be available in dark pink and
light blue color options except I'm a
little sad because this is just the
regular this is the base models it's the
15 not the 15 Pro not the 15 Pro Max
like we want those colors too over here
in the Pro Department do you think that
we don't want that we do I do let me see
a show of hands of anybody else that
might I just think that we need a little
more Dynamic okay Tyler's over there
hand is raised Pro Models need more
Dynamic colors I love the purple color
of the iPhone 14 but like it wasn't
purple enough like you should have just
went all the way like make it purple
make it Pink this is this is beautiful
this is absolutely just love that pink
love that blue like that's we want that
over in the Pro Department iPhone 15 Pro
exclusive design so it looks like there
will be a few design changes that are
exclusive in 15 Pro and 15 Pro Max it's
saying that it's gonna feature thinner
more curved bezels the iPhone 14 Pro
Models and you can see that up here at
those renders you can tell like the
corners are a little bit more rounded
the pro lineup is expected to feature
more curved front glass that better
disappears into the frame that's going
to look nice it's going to kind of
remind you probably a little more like
the Apple watch How It's more rounded
and the glass kind of Blends into the
frame that's gonna look really nice this
is also something that's interesting the
butt
but with Apple updating solid state
volume and power buttons that would be
similar to the home button in the iPhone
7 and the force touch trackpad on
MacBooks kind of cool like I'm into this
but I'm also curious how this is going
to affect case manufacturers because if
you actually have to be like touching it
like it's more of a forced touch so I
don't know how that's going to affect
cases but it says the solid state button
would use haptic feedback to instead
mimic the feel of a brought and press so
it's not going to be like a real button
in theory I'm into it but like execution
wise like how is this going to affect us
with cases because I still I mean I use
this silicon case which obviously if
this is an apple case I'm sure Apple
will make a case that will take full
advantage of this will this make it
difficult for third-party manufacturers
to make cases probably here's a nice
little render we'd love to see it no
touch ID yeah I've given up we've I'm
not even We're not gonna have Touch ID
like it's fine I don't even I'm not even
asking for it at this point it's fine
here's some camera updates apple is
expected to adopt so Sony's latest
state-of-the-art image sensors for the
iPhone 15 models we love to see it
compared to standard sensors Sony's
image sensor doubles the saturation
signal in each pixel allowing to capture
more light to cut down on underexposure
and overexposure the sensor will allow
for improvements in portraits and other
images even when strong backlighting is
an issue this is going to be kind of
interesting they're saying that they may
use a periscope zoom lens technology for
the iPhone 15 Pro Max so we've
definitely have heard these rumors in
the past but this will be limited to the
larger size iPhone 15 Pro Max this is
nothing new Apple has done this in the
past it was on the iPhone not the last
one so it was the 13 or maybe was it the
12th I think it was a 13 when they added
in the Pro Max version had the larger
Zoom range on the telephoto so it's not
surprising but I'm going to be
interested to try that out Periscope
blend technology offers optical zoom
capabilities that exceed those
possibilities with a standard telephoto
lens allowing for 5 effects or even 10 x
optical zoom I mean that's going to be a
pretty significant change if you're able
to get 5x up to 10x optical zoom on your
iPhone that's game changing digital Zoom
is a whole other story you'll still be
able to zoom in even further but that's
kind of just digital and it's not going
to be as clear as Optical Qualcomm modem
chips Apple will be using qualcomm's 5G
modem ships for the 2023 F15 love to see
it oh the rumors suggesting that Apple
could use its own in-house modem chips
as soon as 2023 but looks like they
won't be ready until 2024. I mean Apple
might as well just bring everything
in-house at this point like they're
doing such a great job with the M1 and
M2 chips like just do it just do it all
take it Wi-Fi 6E leaked iPhone 15 Wi-Fi
chip diagrams confirmed that Apple's
upgrading to Wi-Fi 6E okay great love
that a series chips release date
September 2023 and then I made the
mistake of clicking on another link that
said iPhone 16 Ultra the iPhone Ultra
like can we just can we just enjoy the
now she says as she continues to read
the article iPhone Ultra it's going to
be Apple's most expensive and
feature-rich iPhone we don't have too
much Insight right now says says the
article okay well yeah I feel like this
is a possibility like having that Ultra
lineup with like the Apple watch Ultra
and an iPhone Ultra I don't know now
that they have the satellite technology
I feel like they could make a legit
satellite phone like they could have
this Ultra be something that you could
then turn on the satellite capabilities
be able to actually interact and chat
and text like you could a regular
satellite phone not just in emergency
situations so I don't think that says
anything about that here but like look
at this look oh my God look at this
design
it's sick it's freaking sick like that
looks great I love this render I love
the attention to detail they have these
buttons look like they're a little bit
more protruding so if you are out hiking
or something you can actually hit them
they also have the orange accents around
the USBC and the little action button
there as well which is pretty cool this
is a really great design and I hope it
actually comes to life maybe this year
who knows speaking of who knows I don't
I just read this all online so I have no
inside knowledge so don't think that I'm
spilling anything that is not already
publicly out there that people have
already speculated on uh I wish I did
but I don't but I'm super hyped about
the future and I actually have been
really enjoying my 14 inch MacBook have
I even told you guys about this I don't
think I edited that video yet well thank
you guys so much for watching I
obviously love looking at rumors and
checking them out so let me know what
you guys think what do you guys think of
this iPhone 16 Ultra maybe it'll be an
iPhone 15 Ultra maybe it'll just be an
iPhone Ultra and it's going to be in a
whole new category of a its own it's not
going to have a number it's going to be
kind of just like the Apple watch Ultra
which I'm hoping that they do a smaller
version of the Apple watch Ultra I still
love it I still use it every single day
except for today I say every single day
and I was like I want to try this one
out because I'm going to dinner so I
wanted to like wear a little like you
know dress it up a little where the gold
looks nice man the ultra it's just it's
so great the battery life so good that
there are days that I don't even charge
it at night and I'm good to go pretty
much the entire next day anyway this has
nothing to do about the uh the Apple
watch Ultra but um I'm gonna end the
video now I'll see you guys later bye
foreign